you should use the calendar to structure
your days because if you know what
you're doing tomorrow it decreases your
anxiety substantially because you need
that kind of structure you need a
pathway you need to have a map and you
need to know where you're located on the
map and you need to know how you're
moving forward and that gives you hope
because you're moving towards goals that
you regard as worthwhile and it stops
you from being anxious because you're
not entirely directionless and lost and
so learning how to manage your time is
useful and you can start with a calendar
you can start with simple things like
you could put in when you're likely to
go to bed and when you're likely to get
up and regulating that's useful that
should be relatively ritualistically
consistent make your calendar your life
this is how you start to live in
intentional life because you've designed
it you've put it in your calendar not
just the business things when we think
about a calendar it's usually your
business stuff okay I got a meeting here
I gotta I gotta send my newsletter out I
have to whatever the things are for your
business life right you're if you're an
entrepreneur you probably have some of
your business things put in your
calendar I'm not talking just about that
I'm talking about your life
talking about how do you live an
intentional Life by structuring
every day
what ends up happening inside of that is
oh my gosh that's too much structure I
can't stick to it that's too it's too
overwhelming I need free time I need
free time in my calendar great put free
time in your calendar
if you know that you need two hours a
week to have nothing in your calendar
okay
then when is that gonna happen
this is how you reduce stress and
anxieties because you've actually
scheduled in your two hour break and
nothing else comes in because when you
don't schedule your break here's what
happens
other things are going to come up that's
a priority other people's emergencies
other people's phone calls and texts and
emails and social media and then what
does what happens you lead back down to
stress anxiety overwhelm
you block off your time you build your
your ideal life
I was talking entrepreneur yesterday who
I'm mentoring and he he his business
blowing up this business is blowing up
it's amazing
um on his way to seven Figures it's
crazy
and he's struggling with his health
going to doctor's appointments
struggling as lots of inflammation and I
suppose you okay so you need to you need
to eat better you need to work out more
you need to have a kind of healthy
lifestyle you you already know this I'm
not telling you anything new
but it's on his calendar
so we loaded his calendar and his
calendar is all of his business stops
like okay well where are you where is
the physical activity in your calendar
and where are you prepping for the meals
that you're going to eat because when
you just show up on a good morning hey
have a great day awesome okay and now
you're really hungry there's nothing
healthy in the fridge what do you do you
go for you go for junk or you go do
takeout
because you didn't plan because it
wasn't in your calendar
you need to schedule it you need to
schedule when you're going to go buy
food if you're going to order out how
many times a week do you want to order
out like schedule this stuff in as Jocko
willing says discipline equals freedom
you want this life it's entirely
possible
but you have to have the discipline in
your calendar to actually follow through
on it
when you find yourself not following the
calendar
it's because of a couple reasons the
first is because
you set goals that are not actually
possible there wasn't enough flexibility
in your calendar right that you say how
many times you set a goal and you said
I'm going to work out every day for for
two hours and then and then what happens
you don't because it's unrealistic
because that's not gonna happen
and what you're also doing is training
yourself that you suck that when you set
goals that you don't follow through
that's a problem
then the next time you set a goal you're
gonna
tell yourself oh I'm not going to do
this one either because I always set
goals and don't follow through you don't
you stop believing in yourself it's not
even other people believing in you you
don't believe in yourself because you've
taught yourself that when you do some
when you say you're going to do
something you don't actually do it
that's a problem
so how do we start to fix that we start
to fix that by actually creating a
calendar that reflects her entire life
so think about your goals let's let's
break this down right step one think
about the life that you want what's the
life that you want
how much time do you want to spend
sleeping how much time do you want to
spend with family how much time do you
want to spend this will change right if
you're a husband wife single kids
anybody sick in a family those will
shift our calendar accordingly but right
now think about your life right now how
much time do you want to spend with your
family how much time you want to spend
in your business how much you want to
how much time you want to spend
do you need for yourself
free time or meditation time or working
out time or going out in nature time how
much time you want to spend planning
that as opposed to randomly hoping that
your day happens as you want it it's not
having no plan and no schedule is the
path to stress and overwhelm
having a decent plan even a poor plan at
the beginning starts to create the
momentum that you need so think about
how much time you want to spend in those
categories because you don't want to
spend all day sleeping you don't you
don't want to spend all day with your
family you don't want to spend all day
with your kids with your husband wife
you don't want to spend all day working
you don't want to spend all day relaxing
either like the idea of work sitting on
the beach might be great right now
because you feel stressed overwhelmed
and may hate your life but you don't
want to spend all day every day at a
beach you would get so bored the trick
is not to escape your current life
because then you're going back to it
right so Escape for two weeks the life
that you hate to then come back to it
the trick is to build a better life and
it starts with an intentional calendar
so think about how much time you want to
spend on the different categories
then step two I would split it up
between things that you need to do daily
and things you need to do either on a
weekly or monthly basis so daily is
daily routine so I have a morning
routine I'll wake up I'll put on music
I'll set the intention for the day I'll
go for a walk outside it's the snowing
in Toronto this morning I still go for
my walk outside I'll do some kind of
workout whether it's swimming or yoga
some kind of workout and then I'll start
my day right what I do is start my day
like my business day those are different
days of the week okay so just do morning
routine and then evening routine so we
bucket these but these are mostly the
same every day evening routine
uh I'll eat dinner with Nina at six I
have blocked off an hour to be able to
spend time with her at seven I'll stream
on my gaming YouTube channel answering
questions from you at eight I'll spend
time with my son Hayden usually playing
Minecraft or catching up or doing
something together nine will sit down
and watch a show with Nina right now
we're watching Wheel of Time on Amazon
10 I'll take the dogs out I'll come back
up I'll clean the dishes and whatever
else needs to be cleaned in the condo 11
o'clock I'm getting ready for bed
reading the book and hopefully passing
out right evening routine pretty
structured pretty similar every day
what it does is make sure I have time
for all the stuff I want to have time
with my son I want to have time with my
wife I want to have time to eat dinner
and not be stressed out and rush into
the next thing I want to make sure that
there's still time to do the family
admin stuff like take the dogs out and
clean the place because
sure if I miss it one day everything
would be fine but if every day I'm not
taking the dogs out and not clean up the
place that's going to cause strain on my
relationship with Nina and also not
being happy with myself right so all
these things are designed now that
structure may sound overwhelming and
crazy for you awesome you have different
goals
maybe you need four hours of open time
every night or four hours of meditation
time every night don't don't take my
calendar I'm just giving you an example
you need to create your calendar for
yourself
so what's your daily morning routine and
daily evening routine put it down create
it
then inside of the week you might have
different different things on different
days I structured my entire day so
Monday's mentoring day I just mentored
my team Tuesday is YouTube day where i'm
filming content today's a Tuesday I
don't know when the video comes out for
you but for me I'm filming on a Tuesday
Wednesday is my project day it's totally
open to work on projects that I want to
work on Thursdays public facing dates
interviews podcasts shows Etc so Tuesday
Thursdays are busy this I'm not being
creative I'm just work work work work
work work work work very little free
time
and I'm doing tons of videos and tons of
interviews Wednesday in the middle is
totally open
like okay all the ideas that I've had
all the projects that I've wanted to do
here's my time in my calendar to do it
because if I didn't have that spot then
I would feel again stressed out
overwhelmed I feel like I'm just
answering all these
messages and just creating content and
just going on people's shows and I have
no time to create my own stuff perfect
Wednesdays Done Right Wednesdays I would
use to write my book
it's the whole day totally open Friday's
my CEO day
where I work on the business instead of
in the business Saturday is fun day
so Saturday if I'm doing anything that's
work related has to be cleared through
Nina first and better be something big
so I lose out on some opportunities
because Saturdays is fun day and then
Sunday is family at midday cleaning up
the condo grocery shopping
Costco whatever whatever needs to get
done that's my life
right that fits for me let me leave the
total worst thing for you it probably is
awesome figure out your life
morning routine evening routine your
entire life not just what you need to do
as an entrepreneur for your business but
for your life as a husband or a wife or
a son or a daughter or a parent your
life time you need for yourself
create it
morning routine evening routine and then
the rest of the week what are you gonna
do it matters this is how you start to
build consistent habits
the next step is to
evaluate at the end of the week how well
you did the whole point isn't to beat
yourself up of how you sucked and how
you missed this and that schedules don't
work for you Etc but to evaluate it's
not that you can't stick to a schedule
it's that the schedule wasn't a good
enough schedule for you
so what needs to change in the schedule
for example for dinner for me
these are these micro tweaks you might
have to make a big tweak but a micro
trick for me was I had my dinner from 5
30 to 6 with Nina
and it just felt too rushed I said okay
well we don't usually take an hour to
eat we eat small meals so we usually eat
it pretty quickly
um so okay half an hour perfect easy
enough time
but it kind of felt rushed getting into
it so even though it doesn't take us a
full hour to eat I book off an hour to
eat that's an example of a micro
adjustment so think about where do you
feel stressed out in your calendar
you've done it for a week right you plan
out your calendar for the next week
perfect morning routine eating routine
what happens during the week during the
day perfect you evaluate at the end of
the week where did you feel stressed
where did it not work out
where did you miss something
and if it's a one-off thing okay fine
something happened but if it's happening
consistently
then your calendar is broken
then you need to spend more time here if
you get to the end of the week and you
feel stressed out overwhelmed what are
you feeling oh I don't have enough time
to myself this is what the the person I
was mentoring yesterday said like I look
at your calendar this week I couldn't do
that I have no time to myself
great scheduling time to yourself
because if you don't schedule it in time
for yourself chances are something's
going to jump on top of it and you'll
never have time for yourself I'm giving
you the answer
so where is time for yourself
oh Saturday morning perfect how much
time you need four hours great put that
in give yourself five hours as a buffer
just in case now you got the time
and protect that time
so it's making those micro adjustments
as you go until your first week if
you've never done this or feels
overwhelming or stressed for you the
first week is probably going to be a
disaster that's okay
you did some of the things that's better
than not doing any of the things so
let's make some progress now at the end
of the week look back and iterate
change it make some micro tweaks okay
that clearly didn't work here okay so
next week I'm going to try doing this
and what you do is get closer and closer
and closer to creating a schedule that
actually fits for who you are for your
goals and it's not going to be my
schedule it's not going to be Steve
Jobs's schedule or Jordan Peterson's
schedule anybody else it's gonna be one
that you designed tailored for you and
then the third last step to it is you're
going to grow and change as a person and
your schedule needs to change and adjust
alongside so there's a very big
difference between having a job and
being an entrepreneur there's also a
difference between being a solo
entrepreneur and then having a team does
it even having five people on your team
or one person to five people to
37 people now for me there's a big
difference in how I need to manage my
time I didn't I have a whole day
dedicated to mentoring I didn't need
that when it's just me
right things have to change if you're
single versus in your relationship or
single versus engaged versus married and
how long you've been married
or if you have kids or not or planning
to have kids right like your your
choices will change as you change as a
human so even if you create the perfect
schedule right now for yourself and
that's reflective of today like it's a
perfect schedule for this week right now
chances are in a couple months you're
gonna have to make some micro tweaks
because something's changed in your life
and that's okay that doesn't mean that
your schedule sucks just means it needs
an evolution as you evolve your schedule
has to evolve with you
you are what you consistently do
and the way to become that person that
you want to build the life that you want
it's not just having some
vision board for yourself
it's by actually putting into your
calendar let your calendar be your
bucket list
that if you start actually living this
life and doing these things it leads to
a happy whole life for you
treat your personal just as important as
your business
everything gets put into the calendar
and then adjust
and now you're building a life that you
want
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
it took me a long time to understand why
there's religious injunctions supporting
humility
to even understand what the word really
meant in that sort of technical sense
and it means something like this it
means what you don't know is more
important than what you know
and that's a lovely thing to then then
what you don't know can start to be your
friend you see people are very defensive
about what they know and for the reasons
we've already discussed but the thing is
you don't know enough and the re you can
tell you don't know enough because your
life is not what it could be and neither
is the life of the people around you you
just don't know enough and so what that
means is that every time you encounter
some evidence that you're ignorant
someone points it out you should be
happy about that because you think oh
you just told me how I'm wrong it's like
great like maybe I had to sift through a
lot of nonsense to get through the real
message that you're telling me but if
you could actually tell me some way that
I'm wrong and then maybe give me a hint
about how to not be wrong like that well
then I wouldn't have to be wrong like
that anymore that that would be a good
thing and you can you can you can embark
on that Adventure by listening to people
and if you listen to people they will
tell you
they'll tell you amazing things if you
listen to them and many of those things
are little tools that you can put in
your toolkit like Batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often and so the
humility element is well
do you want to be right
or do you want to be learning
and then it's deeper than that it's do
you want to be the the tyrannical King
who's already got everything figured out
or do you want to be the continually
transforming hero or fool for that
matter who's getting better all the time
and that's actually a choice you know
it's a deep choice and it's better to be
the self-transforming fool who's humble
enough to make friends with what he or
she doesn't know and to listen when
people talk and listening is a
transformative exercise like if if you
listen to the people in your life for
example if you actually listen to them
they'll tell you what's wrong with them
and how to fix it and what they want
they can't even help it if you start
listening because people are so shocked
if you actually listen to them that they
they tell you all those sorts of things
that they might not have even intended
to things they don't even know and then
you can you can work with that and so
and the other thing that's so
interesting you know now and then you
have a meaningful conversation right you
need to have a good conversation with
someone you walk with you think geez you
know what we really connect did and I
know more than I did when I came away
from that conversation and during the
conversation you're really engrossed in
it and that that that feeling of being
engrossed is a feeling of meaning and
the feeling of meaning is engendered
because you're having a transformative
conversation so your brain produces that
feeling of meaning for it says oh yeah
this is exactly where you should be
right here and now it's it's the right
place and time for you and that's a
great place to occupy and so a good
conversation where people are listening
has exactly that nature and the reason
it has that nature is because it is in
fact transformative it's one of the
truisms of of Clinical Psychology like
if you're a clinical psychologist a huge
part of what you do is just listen to
people it's like you know they come in
they're unhappy and they'd rather not be
something like that you say well why do
you think you might be unhappy and they
don't know they have some ideas and they
may have to ramble around for like a
year before they figure out why they're
unhappy they get rid of a bunch of
reasons
why they thought they were unhappy that
are untrue and then you kind of get to
the heart of the problem and then you
might ask them well if you could have
what you wanted so that your life would
be okay what would that look like then
they have to ramble around a bunch about
that because they don't really know but
the listening will straighten them out
because people think by talking and in
order to think you have to have someone
to listen because it's very hard to
think hardly anyone can think and even
the people who can think can only think
about a limited number of things the
best thing you can do is teach people to
write because there's no difference
between that and thinking and one of the
things that just blows me away about
universities is that no one ever tells
students why they should write something
it's like well you have to do this
assignment
well why are you writing well you need
the grade it's like no
you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you Undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely deadly nothing can get in
your way
so that's why you learn to write it's
like
when I can't believe that people aren't
just told that it's it's like
it's the most powerful weapon you can
possibly provide someone with and I mean
I know lots of people who've been
staggeringly successful and watched them
throughout my life I mean those people
you don't want to have an argument with
them they'll just slash you into pieces
and not in a malevolent way it's like if
you're gonna make your point and they're
going to make their point you better
have your points organized because
otherwise you're going to look like and
be an absolute idiot you are not going
to get anywhere and if you can formulate
your arguments coherently and make a
presentation if you can speak to people
if you can lay out a proposal God people
give you money they give you
opportunities you have influence
that's what you're at University for if
you're harmless you're not virtuous
you're just harmless you're like a
rabbit a rabbit isn't virtuous it's just
it just can't do anything except get
eaten it's not virtuous
if you're a monster and you don't act
monstrously then you're virtuous but you
also have to be a monster while you see
this all the time Harry Potter's like
that too it's like he's he's flawed he's
hurt he's got evil in him he can talk to
snakes man he breaks rules all the time
all the time he's not obedient at all
but you know he has a good reason for
breaking the rules and it if he couldn't
break the rules him and his little
Clique of rule-breaking you know
troublemakers if they didn't break the
rules
they wouldn't attain the highest goal so
it's very peculiar but it's it's very
very it's a very very very very very
common mythological notion you know the
hero has to be
negro has to be a monster
but a controlled monster Batman is like
that you know I mean it's everywhere
it's it's the story you always hear
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday and not to who someone else is
today
yeah because if you're comparing
yourself to someone else I mean first of
all you don't know very much about the
life of the person you're comparing
yourself to you don't know and it know
it across all of its dimensions and
second people are very different and so
comparing yourself to someone else
it's it's kind of useful I guess when
you're young but as you get older and
more singular and more particular it
becomes increasingly less useful better
to compare yourself to a previous
version of yourself and work for
improvement in that way I know you
stated in the last
um
uh lecture that the importance for
setting AIMS in life and um uh to kind
of have goal goals to uh work towards
right so my question was
um where do you how do you do that if
you don't know where you want to go
because that's kind of where I got stuck
on your your future off authoring
program because okay that's that's a
good question that's a really good
question this notion in the Old
Testament that morality is following a
sequence of prohibitions there's a bunch
of bad things you shouldn't do and then
basically you're good enough and and I
think there's wisdom in that I I think
that's kind of where children start
right you you I mean I love children and
all that but they're they're they're
crazy little creatures and they need to
be you know civilized and well partly
what you do is you you lay prohibitions
on them and mostly what you're trying to
do is lay prohibitions on them
for the behaviors that if they
manifested would make their life
miserable this is why this thing that
I've said to people has become this
crazy internet meme but that's to clean
up your room and which is a lot better
and more useful than people think it's a
lot harder too but the the thing the
first thing you do I think and I learned
this in part from Soldier nipsen when he
was trying to iron out his soul when he
was in the gulag because he was trying
to figure out how he got there how he
contributed to how he got there you know
not Stalin and Hitler even though they
were kind of to blame you know but there
was much he could do about that I think
what you have to do and this is part of
humility is you have to look around you
within your sphere of influence like the
direct sphere of influence and fix the
things that announce themselves as in
need of repair and those are often small
things you know and they can be like
your room put it in order because the
thing is it isn't exactly so important
that your room is in order although it
is what's important is that you learn
how to distinguish between Chaos and
Order and to be able to act in a manner
that produces order I think you can you
can do something as simple as just sit
on your bed and think okay there's
probably like five things I could do
today so that tomorrow morning is
slightly better than this morning was at
least or at least I'm not falling behind
and those will usually be it's like
having to eat a toad in the morning
right it's like it's not going to be
something you want to do there'll be
things you're trying to avoid there's
snakes essentially but if you ask
yourself like you're asking someone
which I think is a form of prayer if you
ask yourself instead of telling yourself
you know what is it that I could do to
set things more right today that I would
actually do it's usually some small
thing because you're not that
disciplined you know then you can go do
it and then you we put the world
together a little more when you do that
and that spreads out but you also put
your you also construct yourself into
something that's better able to call
order forth from chaos and that makes
you just incrementally stronger and then
the next day you can maybe take on a
slightly larger task and like you get
the benefit of compound interest if you
do that it's a term tremendously
powerful technique and I think if you do
that at some point instead of just
having to fix things up that are not
good you'll start to get a glimmer of
the positive things that you could do
you know the positive things that you
could do that would actually constitute
a vision and that that's what I would
recommend when people are beset with a
catastrophe like let's say the death of
their father
that they are prone to use that as an
excuse
for not going about the business that
they should be going about because they
can say to themselves well I would
accept
and except there's always good reasons I
mean believe me there's always good
reasons for not doing what you should
that's for sure the reasons pile up day
after day to not do what you should
especially because you're you're aiming
at things in the future you can put them
off indefinitely right because of the
demands of the day there's no excuse
whatsoever
for not getting at what it is that you
should be doing it's absolutely
reprehensible to justify your inaction
with a catastrophe that extracts Mercy
from other people right there's a tricky
tricky game that's going well of course
I can't do that look at the terrible
thing that's just happened to me and say
okay I understand you're absolved of any
necessity to move forward because of
your current catastrophe it's like well
actually you're not and it's rather rude
of you to use it as an excuse and it's
certainly counterproductive when I was
25 or so I probably weighed about 138
pounds I smoked like a pack of
cigarettes a day I drank
tremendous amount of alcohol I was from
Northern Alberta this rough little town
up in Northern Alberta called Fairview
and you know there were long Winters
there and my friends were heavy Drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on the oil rigs and you know it
was a rough town and we drank a lot and
I started when I was 14 and you know um
and so I was I had a lot of bad habits
let's say and uh things that were and I
wasn't in great shape physically and I
was also still intellectually obsessed
by as I am now and uh
so that would have been that would have
been an 85 but when I but I decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that I was
really going to try to get my act
together I had a fine time when I was a
kid and but uh I needed really to get
disciplined and I had to do it because
I was working on these hard problems
that you know that I've been discussing
with all of you and I've been working on
them really you know obsessively since I
was probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that and got to the point around 25
when I was in graduate school trying to
get my phds doing all my research like I
published 15 papers by the time I
graduated with my PhD which was by I
think by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any graduate student at that
time had ever published at McGill I
think that's right might have been twice
as many or maybe twice as many maybe
even three times as many and at the same
time I wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible terribly difficult
thing to do because I was writing about
three hours a day doing that and I
couldn't do all that and continue with
my misbehavior you know my sort of my
what what would you say my my my
hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that I just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
I had to stop that's a sacrifice I had
to stop you're actually tougher than you
think you never knew that and maybe you
didn't want to take on the
responsibility because you know people
play a role in their own demise so to
speak when you had opportunity to go out
and explore or withdraw because you were
afraid you chose to withdraw because you
were afraid so it's not only that you
were overprotected often it's that you
were willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were overprotected and run
back there whenever you had the
opportunity you know so maybe you're a
kid in the playground right and you're
having some trouble with other kids and
you know in the back of your mind I
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene and you know that
that's not right you know that you're
breaking the social contract but it's
easier and so that's what you do you run
off to an authority figure and hide
behind the great father right roughly
speaking well the problem with that is
you don't learn how to do it yourself so
then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40. so then you take people
out
you say well what are you afraid of rank
it from one to ten
so 10 is make a list of 10 things you're
afraid of the least the thing you're
least afraid of we'll call number ten so
we'll start with that okay well I'm
afraid of elevators okay well let's
let's look at a picture of an elevator
let's have you imagine being in an
elevator let's go out to an elevator and
let you watch the terrible jaws of death
open because that's how you're
responding to it symbolically right and
you're going to do that at it at the the
closest proximity you can manage you
find out you go do that it works you're
nervous as hell especially in from an
anticipatory perspective shaking you go
out you stop you watch it happen and you
actually calm down you do that 10 times
and it no longer bothers you well what
you've learned that you didn't die but
more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death that's what you've
learned and then you move a little
closer and then you move a little closer
and then you move a little closer and
finally you're back in what's no longer
the elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
hmm turns out I can withstand that and
then you're met much more together much
more confident and that's often one of
the things that often happens in
situations like that I've seen this
multiple times is that
if you run someone through an exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up a man of renown but he
was old
but he was also willfully blind and it
was the combination of his age and his
willful blindness that allowed Seth to
chop him up into pieces and and depose
him and so that well that fair enough
it's brilliant right it's like why do
states Fall Apart
because the structures get old and no
one's taking care of them and people
have their eyes closed
and so it's the same situation it's the
same situation in the flood myths it's
like well yeah Things Fall Apart and
they're going to flood but if you were
awake enough
and you were on top of it then you could
continually Stave that off and actually
partly what you're doing
because you're alive is staving off
entropy like you're an anti-entropic
process that's a really good definition
of life there's a great physicist named
Irwin Schrodinger who wrote a book
called what is life and that's the
fundamental thesis of the book you're
always trying to Stave off entropy
what's the best way to Stave off entropy
Decay chaos keep your eyes open
that's the rule shut your eyes
especially to things you know you should
see the flood comes and that's the evil
of man that's laid out in this story
because that's the worst sort of perhaps
it's not the worst it's one of the
primary sins so to speak that will bring
about the flood we already talked about
the other things that characterize
Cain's attitude so
here we go
so God's upset because he made man on
Earth and it grieved him at his heart
and God says I will destroy man whom I
have created from the face of the Earth
both man and Beast and the creeping
thing and the Falls of the air for I
Repent that I have made them but Noah
found Grace in the eyes of the Lord okay
so that's an interesting thing so here
what we have is
the question is
The Whole World's in chaos at this point
right in this point in the story and the
chaos is of multiple sorts it's it arose
from the fall it Rose from the emergence
of self-consciousness it emerged safe it
Rose from the sins of of Cain like
things are not going well it's multiple
levels of collapse B I had a plumber
once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and he had put in
all the plastic piping you know and I
was going to test the joints these are
supposed to be glued together with this
pipe glue right and I said I told him I
had to test the joints and he said well
you don't have to test my joints they
never leak and I thought yeah that's
okay how about if I test them so I went
up on the third floor and filled the
pipes with water capping them in the
basement like you're supposed to and
like half an hour later I had two inches
of water in the basement there were 30
leaking joints that was the night before
the drywallers were supposed to show up
so well so he wasn't particularly
competent that's the point of that story
but even more so he had put a bunch of
the plastic pipe outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so I
spent a frenetic night you know sawing
through plastic pipe and re-gluing
Joints so that my well so that the dry
rollers could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a Tradesman and
you can be you can make a lot of money
as a tradesperson it's a bloody reliable
honorable uh forthright productive way
of making a living and there is a hell
of a lot of difference between a working
man who knows what he's doing and one
who doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
bloody pleasure they tell you what
they're going to do they tell you how
much it will cost they go and do it it
works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you to listen to these
panderers of egalitarianism
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people it's
not such a terrible thing man maybe you
wouldn't be a great lawyer like it's
certainly possible most people aren't
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one go try in another
but the point is you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do if you don't try to aim
for the top you know flop about
uselessly and whine about your life it's
not helpful it'll just make you
miserable you're not reliable to anyone
you can't help out in a crisis it's like
so you tell young people and this is
another message for conservatives like I
don't care what you're going to do but
go out there and make something of
yourself for God's sake be an honest
person and work and get to the top of
whatever it is that you want to get to
the top of you know and and and and that
stand up for yourself like a respectable
human being and be a bit of a light on
the world instead of a blight you know
and you can tell young people pulled out
and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's it's painful
to watch they're so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody World beater they think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting that might make
life or life worth living it's like yeah
it might so why don't you go do it
that's what the damn universities were
supposed to be teaching people they've
forgotten that I went to Harvard a month
ago month and a half I used to teach
there and I talked to a bunch of
students you know and I told them it's
not easy to get into Harvard you know
like you're a valedictorian if you're at
Harvard and not only are you a
valedictorian you're way better than
most people at at least two other things
or you don't get in and so like it's I
don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent and believe me not
everybody applies so it's a very
selective school and so why am I saying
that it's like these are high quality
kids so I told them what I just told you
it's like here you are at Harvard it's
like get yourself educated man read some
books learn to talk learn to think make
yourself into something get the hell out
there and make the world that put you
here happy that you were put there in
that great institution you know and they
came up to me afterwards and said God I
wish someone would have told us that
when we were in our first year it's like
Jesus why didn't someone tell them that
for God's sake it's supposed to be the
greatest University in the world is it
so difficult to figure that out you're
lost and the problem with being lost is
when you're lost you don't know where to
go and the problem with not knowing
where to go is there's a million places
that you could go and a million places
is too many places for you to go without
dying so being lost is not good so you
need to know where you are you can kind
of tell if you don't know where you are
it's quite straightforward
if you are haunted by reveries of the
past
for events that are older than
approximately 18 months if they continue
to come up in your mind over and over in
your dreams over and over
you haven't extracted the world out from
your past experiences the potential is
still trapped in the past you're a
navigator you're a sailor on an ocean
man that's what that's what you are
you're a mobile creature you're going
from point A to point B all the time
you're not sitting there glued to a rock
like some brainless you know sea
creature there's a funny little creature
called a Hydra
very simple little creature in its
juvenile stage it has a brain because it
swims around but then when it turns into
an adult it latches itself to a rock and
promptly digests its brain because if
you're just sitting on a rock and you're
not moving you don't need a brain so but
that's not our issue right we're we're
zipping around in the world and so we're
navigating agents and so to navigate and
there's two things you need to know
the first is where the hell are you
exactly precisely right razor sharp
what's good about you and what's bad
about you buy your own buy your own
Reckoning you don't have to you can ask
other people but this is a game you play
yourself it's like as far as I'm
concerned
I'm taking stock what is it that's okay
about me and What needs some work and
you got to watch to not be too
self-critical when you're doing that too
because that can just be another kind of
flaw I'm really sad to see that people
are disenchanted and nihilistic and
depressed and anxious and aimless and
and perverse and vengeful and and all of
those things it's terrible and then to
see people
question whether that's necessary and
then to start to rise out of it it's
like it's so fun like last night I was
at after my talk it's overwhelming
foreign
think about these things but I was I was
after my talk last night and so all
these people line up and you know they
have their 15 15 seconds with me and
they're kind of tentative they're
excited and attentive when they come up
to talk to me and then they have you
know 15 seconds of time to tell me
something I'm really listening to them
and they're hesitant about whether or
not to share the good news about their
life you know and I think it's often
because
when people share good news about their
life people don't necessarily respond
positively you know they don't get
encouragement and people need so little
encouragement it's just unbelievable and
so they'll tell me something good and I
think oh that's so good you know
somebody says oh I'm getting a long way
better with my father I haven't seen him
for 10 years and now we get along it's
like God great and then the power of
that you can't overstate the power of
that for individuals to get their life
together the individuals an unbelievably
powerful force and every single person
who gets their act together a little bit
has the capacity to spread that around
them it's it's a chain reaction one of
the things that's really interesting
about the Old Testament is that and the
Jews in the Old Testament is that they
don't take the path of Cain every time
they're walloped by God which is like
fairly frequently they say we must have
done something wrong and we have to set
ourselves right
and that's a an unbelievably heroic
attitude because that's the alternative
to cursing fate it's like you take the
responsibility for failure unto yourself
and you think well if I was just maybe
if I just had my act together a little
bit more if I took advantage of every
opportunity that was put in front of me
if I wasn't resentful and bitter then I
could have done something that would
have tilted the situation in a different
direction and like that's almost
inevitably true Dostoevsky I think said
something like every man is responsible
for everything that happens to him and
everything that happens to everyone else
and that's you know that that's that's a
it's a crazy statement right it's a
crazy statement and he was a pretty
extreme person in many many ways but
there's a level at which that's
metaphysically true you know because
what happens is that
it's it's failure to act often that's
the most catastrophic you know I mean
I've uh it's it's it's to not do the
right thing when the when the situation
presents itself and it's very specific
you know you're constantly in situations
where
you could do the right thing if you were
willing to take a risk that's actually
of relatively moderate size
and you know that you could take the
risk and you know that you should take
the risk and you don't and that happens
to people all the time and then what
happens is the thing that they didn't
oppose grows a little bit and they
shrink a little bit and that starts a
loop hey I noticed that there's always a
group of
of my friends who always criticize what
I'm saying and not even try to
understand what I'm where I'm coming
from and um I've I've always wondered
how to deal with that I mean I want to
listen to what they're saying but
um they are not understanding what I'm
they're not trying to listen to what I'm
saying so what would you do in that
situation can I answer that very briefly
okay
okay there's a line in the New Testament
that's relevant to that
do not cast Pearls Before Swine
and what that means is that if people
are not listening to you
stop talking to them
and that's really that is the best piece
of advice that I can give you and what
happens is that if you stop talking to
people who aren't listening to you and
start watching them instead they will
tell you what they're up to
but so if you have things to say say
them but you find people that will
listen talk to them the ones who aren't
listening pull back
because you're you're devaluing what you
have to say by offering it to an
audience that does nothing but reject it
and that's a good guideline to life in
general so pull back psychologists
have been
not all psychologists obviously but the
psychological profession is is neck deep
in this in this pathology has been
beating the self-esteem drum for 50
years Oh no you're okay you should feel
good about yourself like you're you're
fine the way you are it's like you think
well that's a calming message for people
it's like no it's not it's not at all
and I watch my audiences it's like it's
full of people in the audience who think
I'm suffering a lot more than I think is
tenable a whole bunch of it's my fault
my life is not in the order it should be
I know I'm doing 50 things wrong it's
like what the hell is wrong with me
what's wrong with the people around me
this is really serious and some you know
well-meaning person comes up and says oh
you're okay just the way you are it's
like no one wants that message it's like
no I'm not okay the way I am I'm not
okay at all the way I am I know that and
so you know when I'm when I'm speaking
to to when I'm speaking now I say to
people well LOL you're nowhere near what
you could be that's the that's the
positive message it's like yeah you're a
mess but you don't have to stay that way
you're a mess you know it obviously
you're suffering away like like so much
you can barely tolerate it it's like
that's okay you can do something about
it if you're hungry and you eat well
that's good but it's over and then
you're on to the next thing right it's
not exactly sustaining it's just
necessary that's called consummatory
reward by the way this other reward
system is incentive reward and the
incentive reward system works on
dopamine this neurochemical dopamine
which is also the neurochemical tracts
that opiates and cocaine and
amphetamines the drugs that people
really like to abuse alcohol often for
some people activate and so you might
say if you don't have enough meaning in
your life then you're more prone to
addiction and that's definitely the case
even with rats if you take a rat you put
them in a cage by himself and he has
nothing to do and then you give him
access to cocaine he'll get addicted to
the point where he won't do anything but
take cocaine but if you throw the rat
back in with a bunch of other rats and
he gets to do rat things then it's very
hard to get them addicted to cocaine and
so the purposeless rat is prone to
addiction well it's the same with human
beings now here's a corollary to that
which is really cool so
the magnitude of the reward you
experience as you're moving towards a
goal is proportionate to the importance
of the goal
so that means the more important the
goal you pick the more possibility there
is for the kind of reward let's say it's
really a state of being that is life
affirming and it is directly life
affirming in that you know like if
you're in a football game and you're and
it's an important football game and
maybe you break a finger and you know
normally that's that's a problem it
hurts and you're going to stop doing
whatever you're doing but if you're
right in the middle of the game then
you'll be so amped up on this reward
system that it's analgesic it stops the
pain it also suppresses anxiety so if
you have a purpose then it's analgesic
it takes some of the pain out of life
it's very positive in that it motivates
and energizes you and focuses you and
makes you able to remember and pay
attention and it it quells fear and so
those things are all direct and so then
you might think well what's the best
possible goal well and that's that's the
purpose I would say of religious
training in philosophical training it's
like just what the hell are you doing in
the world tell the truth or at least
don't lie yeah well it's not that easy
to tell the truth because who knows
about the truth but you can learn not to
say things that you know to be false and
if you stop saying things that you know
to be false then your life will improve
a lot it simplifies it and it puts you
in alignment with reality and you should
be in alignment with reality because
there's a lot more of it than there is
of you first of all you have to treat
yourself like you matter because if you
don't then you don't take care of
yourself and you become vengeful and and
and cruel and you you take you take it
out on people around you and you're not
a positive force none of that's good so
you suffer more and so does everyone
around you and there's a malevolence
that enters into it none of that's good
so that's what happens if you don't
treat yourself like you matter and then
what happens if you don't treat other
people like they matter well you lie to
them you cheat them you steal you you
enter into impulsive relationships with
them they can't trust you that doesn't
go anywhere they don't like you you end
up alone at best and maybe like in in
car incarcerated at worst like that
doesn't work and so you watch the people
around you who Thrive regardless of what
they say they act out the proposition
that everyone matters and then you have
a functional society and I think okay
well if if when you act out the
proposition that everyone matters you
have a functional Society maybe that's
evidence that that proposition is true
it's like I think it's I think it's true
if you're failing repeatedly
um then there's probably something wrong
it's possible that there's something
wrong with the way that you're
conceptualizing the world because you
have a choice right if if you keep
making sacrifices and they don't work
there's a binary choice and one is well
there's something
wrong with the structure of reality
and the other is there's something wrong
with your approach and so then you might
say well let's take the first idea
there's something wrong with the
structure of reality it's like you're
really going to say that are you you're
really going to come out and say I know
enough to judge the nature of being
and and then the alternative is also
quite frightening because then you know
you it's you that's making the mistakes
and you might be wrong at a really deep
level and that might mean that a lot of
you has to burn off and be transformed
maybe even things about yourself that
you think are admirable and that you
like because your position you know your
yourself conceptualization is so warped
and wrong and that's really daunting but
you know when people set themselves up
as the judge of being I mean I've
written about this a fair bit in my new
book which is called 12 rules for life
when people set themselves up as the
judge of being then they take on what
can only be described as a kind of
satanic arrogance because they've
actually taken to themselves the moral
right to criticize the structure of
existence itself it's like you better be
careful when you do something like that
there's another rule in my book which is
Rule nine assume that the person that
you're listening to knows something you
don't well they do the person you're
listening to knows some things you don't
you can be sure of that now whether or
not you can get to them is a different
matter but if you do get to them it's a
real deal for you that's why you want to
listen to the other person's arguments
is because you're not everything you
could be you don't know the pathway
forward with as much clarity as you
could and it's possible this is one of
the wonderful things that I've had the
privilege of experiencing as a clinician
you know because people it's like I live
inside a Dostoevsky novel as a clinician
people come in and they tell me about
their lives and I listen to them and
they tell me things that are just
absolutely beyond belief you know and I
learn from my clients constantly they're
they're telling me honestly about their
experience they tell me things they
wouldn't tell anyone else because I
actually listen to them but part of the
reason I listen is because I'm desperate
to listen it's like there's a
possibility I'm going to do something
stupid in the next five years that's
going to be like fatal and there's some
small possibility that if we have a
decent discussion that you'll tell me
something that will eliminate some of my
blindness so that I don't have to fall
into that particular pit and if you have
a good sensitivity for the depth of the
pit then you know you're pretty bloody
motivated to avoid it and so and that
and and that and that dialogue is it's
it's dialogic it's dial Logos right it's
shared logos it's the way that we redeem
ourselves mutually moving forward I like
this one and I think I mean this is very
clearly what you do be precise in your
speech
Isis one of the things God has Adam do
first so God makes the World by speaking
okay so that's the first thing to think
about
you're supposed to think like in a
sophisticated way about this that the
idea is that there's some integral
relationship between communication and
the structure of being
it's part of the role that Consciousness
plays in the world whatever that role is
language
takes the chaos and makes it into things
and so
God has Adam name all the animals
they're not even really real until they
have names
now they're more implicit that's another
you know here's a here's an example
let's say that
you're having a rough patch in your
relationship
and you don't know why it's unnameable
is it real well yeah it's manifesting
itself in a like a physiological
discomfort
then you talk about it and you name it
it's like it goes from this blurry thing
that's kind of potential it goes snap
and then it's this thing right and then
that's a horrible thing it's like a
little poisonous thing but it's not a
whole foggy cloud of potential poison
it's like this little sharp poison thing
then you think okay
it's real it's a little monster but it's
not it's little at least and now
probably we can do something about it if
we can admit to it so it's this
Precision that specifies and like so
this is a little bit of the Voldemort
effect right if since you're a Harry
Potter guy they wouldn't name right this
is the problem we got to name them first
oh yeah you got to name them first
absolutely because the unnameable is far
more terrifying than the nameable you
see that in there was this great Blair
Witch Project terrifying movement yeah
well it's unnamed there's nothing
terrible happens in that movie it's all
the unnamable it's like what's going on
what's going on what's going on and no
matter how terrible the actuality is
it's rarely as terrible as your
imagination because your imagination
like it's an old thing it's seen a lot
of terrible things in the history of
life like it can put Monsters Everywhere
and so it's almost always better
it might be better without exception to
name the thing no matter how terrible it
is and if you can't name it what that
means is that you're you're telling
yourself that you're so terrified that
you can't bring your attention to bear
on it and that makes you you're the
loser instantly if it's so terrifying
that you cannot face it it's one stand
up straight with your shoulders back my
wife is a massage therapist and she's
very physiologically aware and so she's
also helped me with this sort of thing
but we watch people on the streets all
the time and people in general now have
very poor posture very bad for them
that's got to be phone related too right
we're all well yeah I think that's part
of it but I also think it's something
our culture doesn't attend to like you
kind of have to remind your kids to
stand up you know it takes a certain
amount of conscious effort but yeah in
that chapter I talk a lot about lobsters
which I'm I'm kind of I kind of have an
affinity for lobsters and because they
well the the short story is that when a
lobster loses a fight
because they're fighting all the time
for dominance let's say in their
hierarchies he kind of crunches down so
he looks smaller when he wins the fight
he stretches out looks bigger and so
he's signaling to other lobsters the
tally of his victories let's say so if a
lobster has won a fight he's more likely
to win the next fight then you would
calculate from having a tally of all his
previous defeats and victories and if he
loses a fight then he's more likely to
lose the next fight so that's that that
Matthew principle at work okay so you
think well so what so what does that
have to do with anything it's like okay
here part of the kicker is
well the lobster runs on serotonin
neurochemical
and if the lobster loses the serotonin
levels go down and if he wins the
serotonin levels go up and when the
serotonin levels go up he stretches out
and he's a confident Lobster and one of
the consequences of that is if a lobster
loses a battle and you give him the
equivalent of antidepressants
then he stretches out he'll go fight
again so antidepressants work on
lobsters right and you think well who
cares it's like no no no you don't get
it
we diverged from lobsters from an
evolutionary perspective 350 million
years ago and it's the same circuit it's
absolutely unbelievable and that shows
you how deep inside you how basic how
primordial that circuit is in you that's
sizing other people up and looking at
where they fit in the hierarchy well
with human society it's more like
hierarchies of competence than dominance
per se but and like if you're
serotonin levels fall
you get depressed you crunch forward and
and the whole everything around you
turns cloudy and black and and then
you're inviting more oppression right
and so you get into this bad Loop you
know and so it's really important to if
you're trying to get your act together
it's really important to stretch
yourself out and and sit up properly
because it's it's part of the
psychophysiological loop that can start
you on the upward curve there's no faith
and no courage and no sacrifice in doing
what is expedient
what do you say to those viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and are locked
into their careers because they are too
afraid to take risks and pursue
something meaningful well the first
thing I would say is well you should be
afraid of taking risks and pursuing
something meaningful
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are if it's making you
miserable it's like the first thing you
want to do is dispense with the idea
that you get to have any any permanent
security outside of your ability to
contend and adapt it's the same issue
with children it's like you're paying a
price by sitting there being miserable
and you might say well the devil I know
is better than the one I don't it's like
don't be so sure of that the clock is
ticking yeah and if you're miserable in
your job now and you change nothing in
five years you'll be much more miserable
and you'll be a lot older but isn't it a
luxury to pursue what is Meaningful our
viewers have more this they have
children they have payments and Loans
it's a luxury to pursue because we lack
the resources well I don't think I don't
remember now I'm not talking about what
makes you happy
it's a luxury to pursue what makes you
happy it's a moral obligation to pursue
what you find meaningful and that
doesn't mean it's easy it might require
sacrifice if you need to change your job
too let's say you have a family and and
and children and a mortgage you have
responsibilities
you've already picked up those
responsibilities you don't just get to
walk away scot-free and say well I don't
like my job I quit that's no strategy
but what you might have to do is you
think well this job is killing my soul
all right so what do I have to do about
that well I have to look for another job
well no one wants to hire me it's like
okay maybe you need to educate yourself
more maybe you need to update your your
curriculum Vita your resume maybe you
need to overcome your fear of being
interviewed maybe you need to sharpen
your social skills like you you have to
think about these things strategically
if you're going to switch careers you
have to do it like an intelligent
responsible person that might take you a
couple of years of of of effort I've
dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and Consulting practice and we
set a goal we develop a vision and work
towards it and it things inevitably get
better for people so it's not a luxury
it's it's difficult it's a moral
responsibility and it isn't happiness
it's it's not the pursuit isn't for how
us the first way in which you captured
the world's attention was at University
and that's what I want to talk about now
because the c-16 law in Canada was being
proposed contextualized for us what it
is precisely that you were being that
you were opposed to in that yeah well
Bill c-16 purported to do nothing but
extend human rights Provisions to an
excluded group let's say to to the
transgender and non-gender binary types
and and that was the Federal legislation
it also made it a hate crime to to to
discriminate or harass essentially so
now then the question is well what
exactly do you mean by discriminate or
harass and why exactly is that a hate
crime under the criminal code well there
was an answer to that the answer was
well this bill will be interpreted in
light of the policies generated by the
Ontario Human Rights Commission very
large set of policies now the Ontario
Human Rights Commission is a radically
leftist organization I think it's the
most dangerous organization in Canada
although you could debate that and they
said all sorts of policies about how
this these led this legislation was
going to be interpreted and the federal
government linked to their website to
state that bill 16 c16 would be
interpreted in light of those guidelines
so I went and read all the policies well
one of the policies was that if you
didn't use the preferred pronouns of a
given group that you could be charged
essentially with a hate crime and I
thought no that's given group is that
you've been talking about transgender
people yeah and so there's all these
pronouns that have come up are 70
different sets of pronouns approximately
to to hypothetically describe people who
don't fit anywhere on the gender
Spectrum which is also something that I
don't really understand I don't
understand that conceptually like we
will come to that yeah
okay so now I'm a person is compelled
under Canadian law to use the pronoun of
another individual's Choice by on pain
of Law and I thought well no that's not
acceptable it's one thing to put limits
on what a person can't say like say with
hate speech laws which I also don't
agree with by the way but that's a
different argument I think it's a
narrower argument but to compel me to
use a certain content when I'm
formulating my thoughts or my actions
under threat of legislative action I
thought no what's happened there is the
government has introduced compelled
speech legislation into the private
sphere it's never happened in the
history of English common law and so I
said there's no way I'm abiding by that
I don't care what your damn rationale is
we're compassionate it's like no you're
not no you're not you're playing this
radical collectivist left-wing game
you're trying to gain linguistic you're
trying to gain linguistic Supremacy in
the in the area of public discourse
you're doing that using compassion as a
guise and you're pulling the wool over
people's eyes we're built for struggle
us human beings not after
um the bubbles of bliss that Dostoyevsky
described in in Notes from Underground
were built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want to challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because a
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and Fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so and I'm not
saying that in a naive way I know
perfectly well what happens to people
you know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later you're dead and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point but that's not the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and contend and you
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do compare yourself to who
you were yesterday and not to who
someone else is today
yeah because if you're comparing
yourself to someone else I mean first of
all you don't know very much about the
life of the person you're comparing
yourself to you don't know and it know
it across all of its dimensions and
second people are very different and so
comparing yourself to someone else
it's it's kind of useful I guess when
you're young but as you get older and
more singular and more particular it
becomes increasingly less useful better
to compare yourself to a previous
version of yourself and work for
improvement in that way life is
difficult and you cannot protect your
children
what you can do is prepare them and you
can prepare them to be strong and
courageous and truthful and resilient
and reciprocal in their interactions
with other people and that means you
equip them for what life will be which
is at minimum a series of difficult
challenges and and often more than that
because of course people go through very
difficult times in their lives and
a resilient person is capable of
standing up to things in the face of
fear and moving forward voluntarily
convinced of their own competence and
ability to Prevail and so the primary
your primary goal as a parent apart from
facilitating your child's social
desirability which is a major
obligation on your part is to encourage
your children and to and I mean that
literally to instill in them a sense of
courage in the face of the difficulties
of life and not to protect them from
that
we don't even want to be protected from
those difficulties because a major part
of life and its meaning is the
the challenge that comes with
confronting difficulties I said with
Bill c-16 that I wouldn't speak the
language of the radical leftists because
I don't think that that language should
Define the game but let's say it does so
here's the game
the world is a battleground of groups
and the they're battling for power
that's it that's the game and some of
them win and they oppress those who
don't win so that's how we're going to
view the world
okay now the left is say okay well
here's the oppressed people the
oppressors
the patriarchy type patriarchal types
they should be ashamed of themselves and
give up some power
the right Wingers the radical
right-wingers look at that and they say
oh I see so the game is ethnic identity
is it it's identity politics okay we're
white males
we're not going to lose
that's the right-wing version of
identity politics it's like screw you
if we're going to divide into groups if
we're going to divide into tribes
and I'm in my tribe I'm not going to get
all guilty and lose
I'm going to get all cruel and win
and that's like then you think well
there's people in the middle they're
kind of looking back and forth which
side of the identity politics Spectrum
am I going to fall in do I want to go
with uh do I want to go do I want to be
driven primarily by compassion and am I
going to accept guilt for my historical
privilege so that's one possibility and
then I'm the oppressor I'm the member of
the oppressor group or am I going to say
oh no to hell with that I'm just going
to play to win well then I'm going to go
to the right
it's like well my sense is how about we
don't play either of those games and the
reason we shouldn't play them is well
the Soviets played the left-wing game
and like killed who knows how many tens
of millions of people you can't even
count it accurately the estimates range
from 20 to 100 million those are pretty
big error bars and the maoists maybe a
hundred million certainly 60 million so
okay that didn't work out so well then
there's the Nazis like they played
ethnic identity politics and racial
superiority it's like why do we want to
play that game
see what I've been trying to do really
what I've been trying to do for the last
30 years is say look
there's heavy Temptations to play those
sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together
stand up in the world make something of
yourself stay away from the ideological
oversimplifications set your house in
order that's rule six in the in the in
this book so I have a book rule in there
says set your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world and it's
a very dark chapter about the
motivations of the Columbine High School
killers and this other guy named Carl
panzram who is a serial rapist and
arsonist and murderer and these he wrote
an autobiography and the Columbine kids
also wrote about why they did what they
did they're resentful to the core bitter
bitter resentful terrible
and
well I'm suggesting that people stay
away from that resentment resentfulness
and bitterness even though life is hard
and and there's malevolence in the world
it's like yeah you can you can tell a
story where everyone's a victim because
we all die we all get sick
you know and and and things happen to us
that are
bitter and terrible betrayal deceit lies
like people heard us on purpose you know
so it's not just the tragedy of life
it's malevolence as well it's everyone's
a victim you can tell that story the
problem is if you tell that story and
you start to act it out you make all of
that worse that's the problem
and it's so this is why partly I got
attracted to Christian imagery at least
in part
um because there's an idea in
Christianity that you should pick up
your goddamn cross and like walk up the
hill and that's
dramatically that's correct
that's the right answer it's like
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust so what are you going to do about
it accept it voluntarily and try to
transform as a consequence that's the
right answer it's the right answer
because the rest of it is tribalism and
we're we're too technologically powerful
to get all tribal again you're
known for providing advice to young men
online many of whom are listening to
your messages
and if I could distill the core message
that you advise young men
to pay attention to it's that they could
be far more than they currently are
could you explain that for me please
well people have
an an unspecified potential for
development
educationally obviously with regards to
the skills they have but also in
relationship to their character and
it's it's much it's much more
encouraging for people I think to
concentrate on who they could be rather
than who they are especially when
they're young because they still have
most of their life ahead of them and and
they're not everything they could be yet
and so to tell people even something
like well you should feel good about
yourself the way you are it's like well
that there's something there that's
seriously lacking
because
there's so much more that you could be
that you need to be and that you should
be aiming at they're telling you the
problem with being okay the way you are
is that you don't have a goal then and
people need to have a goal in order to
to come to terms with their life the
baboon here who's supposed to be
basically just a fool when the story was
first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that will turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
Central and that would be say like The
Rock in The Pride Rock in The Lion King
because you take yourself out of your
Dopey little village and that's just a
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
because you're becoming informed which
means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too primary motive as a clinical
psychologist and educator is to help
individual schools live more meaningful
and productive lives in harmony with
their families and their Community
that's my motive
and the evidence for that I think is
well if people go online and first of
all you can watch the lectures and
decide for yourself but you can also go
there's I suspect probably
maybe 250 000 people have commented on
the lectures and their effects on them
and so
that's what people say I'm watching the
lectures yeah I'm trying to develop a
vision for my life I'm trying to become
more responsible and it's really helping
and that's and that's what I hear all
the time when I do these public lectures
which which aren't political but when we
gain success we raise the bar we set our
Ambitions higher I mean what is your
ranking what do you want that's all
that's what I want I want I want to help
as many individuals as possible become
more courageous
more truthful and more engaged in the
pursuit of
individual familial and social harmony
that's what I want well there's
something I'd like to say maybe in
closing about courage people say that to
me and you know I don't think it's
exactly right there's there's a line in
the Old Testament the fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom and I think it's
more like that it's not that I'm
courageous it's that I'm afraid of the
right things
so when I made my videos it wasn't like
that didn't make me nervous
but I was less nervous about going back
to bed and not saying what I had to say
than I was about making the videos
because I know where this is going
I don't want to go there and so
it's it's not so much courage it's that
it's a matter of
I it's it's it's less risky to say
something
than to remain silent when you know
there's something to be said I know that
to be the case and so lots of times in
life it's like there's no pathway
forward that's going to Shield you from
risk you get to pick this risk or you
get to pick this risk and I think I
picked the Lesser risk and that might be
wise but I'm not so sure it's courageous
oh yes chapter nine is assume that the
person you are listening to might know
something you don't
this is a chapter about conversation and
about the different forms conversation
takes
it's a chapter about humility
and it's a chapter about listening and
the humility element is it took me a
long time to understand why there's
religious injunctions supporting
humility
to even understand what the word really
meant in that sort of technical sense
and it means something like this it
means what you don't know is more
important than what you know
and that's a lovely thing to then then
what you don't know can start to be your
friend you see people are very defensive
about what they know and for the reasons
we've already discussed but the thing is
you don't know enough and the re you can
tell you don't know enough because your
life is not what it could be and neither
is the life of the people around you you
just don't know enough and so what that
means is that every time you encounter
some evidence that you're ignorant
someone points it out you should be
happy about that because you think oh
you just told me how I'm wrong it's like
great like maybe I had to sift through a
lot of nonsense to get through the real
message that you're telling me but if
you could actually tell me some way that
I'm wrong and then maybe give me a hint
about how to not be wrong like that well
then I wouldn't have to be wrong like
that anymore that that would be a good
thing and you can you can you can embark
on that Adventure by listening to people
and if you listen to people they will
tell you
they'll tell you amazing things if you
listen to them and many of those things
are little tools that you can put in
your toolkit like Batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often and so the
humility element is well
do you want to be right
or do you want to be learning
and then it's deeper than that it's do
you want to be the the tyrannical King
who's already got everything figured out
or do you want to be the continually
transforming hero or fool for that
matter who's getting better all the time
and that's actually a choice you know
it's a deep choice and it's better to be
the self-transforming fool who's humble
enough to make friends with what he or
she doesn't know and to listen when
people talk and listening is a
transformative exercise like if if you
listen to the people in your life for
example if you actually listen to them
they'll tell you what's wrong with them
and how to fix it and what they want
they can't even help it if you start
listening because people are so shocked
if you actually listen to them that they
they tell you all those sorts of things
that they might not have even intended
to things they don't even know and then
you can you can work with that if you
want another amazing Jordan Peterson
video check it out right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there